laschet schwenkt um und will einen
harten bundesweiten corona kurs weniger
kontakte keine lockerungen er nennt das
brücken lockdown kommt dass corona
notabene prüfungen ein vorschlag der
gewerkschaft gew sorgt für wirbel
grund die gefährliche anziehungskraft
von feuer blut und hitze auf island
stoppen die behörden jetzt den run auf
den vulkan
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abenden willkommen
bei den nachrichten am ostermontag den
sport gibt es heute von norbert könig
genannt
der kampf gegen die dritte welle könnte
nochmals zu verschärften corona regeln
für nordrhein-westfalens
ministerpräsident laschet fordert heute
einen kurzen und harten brücken lockdown
bis zu dem zeitpunkt wenn viele menschen
geimpft sein
so lange müsse noch mal nachgelegt
werden darin sei er sich mit kanzlerin
und gesundheitsminister sparen einig
außerdem sollten länder chefs und
chefinnen schon diese woche
zusammenkommen wenn ihr chef armin
laschet besucht ein impfzentrum in
aachen
er war zuletzt wie einige andere
länderchefs auch für seinen corona kurs
von der kanzlerin kritisiert wurden
heute fordert er neue mpk runde noch
diese woche und weitere maßnahmen
angesichts der dritten infektionswelle
deshalb glaube ich brauchen wir einen
wir müssen die brücke hin zu dem
zeitpunkt wo viele menschen geimpft sind
noch einmal bauen
ich weiß dass viele menschen müde von
der pandemie sind aber dass auch viele
bereits sind jetzt noch einmal einen
schritt zu gehen konkret zelte auf mehr
home office auch ausgangssperren bei
schulen und kitas nur das notwendigste
und er sei sich mit der kanzlerin und
vielen ministerpräsidenten einig mit dem
chef der mpk ist er es nicht
ja es ist glaube ich noch sehr viel
unklarer verlasse damit meint ein
brücken lockdown für eine übergangszeit
und dann mit welchen maßnahmen und das
soll so lange gelten bis viele menschen
geimpft sind was heißt das alles also
ich glaube da sind viele überlegungen
auch bei under schritt noch nicht
abgeschlossen und insofern glaube ich
mache es auch keinen sinn jetzt
vorfristig zu einer
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
zusammenzukommen
das problem ist einfach die zeit die wir
verloren haben seit über einem monat
seit über einem monat wissen wir dass
die zahlen nach oben gehen
und das ist klar wir brauchen jetzt
entschiedene maßnahmen
der mann neben armin laschet ist chef
der deutschen intensivmediziner und er
warnt die nächsten 12 wird sind tage
gehen wir fest davon aus dass die
steigerungsraten der letzten wochen sich
fortsetzen das heißt dass wir fünf oder
auch mehr 1000 patienten mit 19 zu
versorgen haben die lage ist also
wirklich sehr dramatischen muss man
sagen und impfen sagt der
gesundheitsminister
werde diese dritte welle nicht brechen
rund 10 millionen menschen sind in
deutschland bislang erst geändert der
frage an theo koll in berlin
theo mit dem sogenannten brücken
lockdown schwenk laschet ja plötzlich
auf die linie von kanzlerin und bayerns
ministerpräsident müller ein
wie ist das zu erklären das ganze hat
eine reihe interessanter aspekte da ist
einerseits dieser neue begriff brücken
lockdown der ja offensichtlich eine
erfindung aus dem pr werkzeugkasten ist
es klingt so als solle der begriff
brücke das gefühl vermitteln dass das
rettende ufer nahe ist anders als bei
den bisherigen düsteren tunnel bild wo
man ja nie weiß wie weit das licht am
ende wirklich entfernt ist vor allem
aber ist es das einschwenken auf die
harte linie mit möglichen ausgangs
beschränkungen ja eine distanz
verringerung zur kanzlerin die den
nordrhein westfälischen
ministerpräsidenten und cdu-vorsitzenden
ja öffentlich für seine flexiblere
haltung kritisiert hatte angesichts der
dritten welle will sich armin laschet
offensichtlich nicht erlauben als
unvorsichtig zu gelten und ab sofort
läuft die entscheidungsphase über die
kanzlerkandidatur der union
söder hat gerade erst betont dass die
kanzlerin dabei mitreden soll er selbst
sieht sich nah an der kanzlerin in
corona fragen und da hat jetzt der
andere unerklärte kandidat gleichgezogen
spannende wochen winter setzt vielen
dank dafür theo koll und das sind die
aktuellen corona zahlen im land das
robert koch institut meldet 8497 neue
infektionen innerhalb eines tages das
sind 1 1375 weniger als im vergangenen
montag 50 neue todesfälle kamen hinzu
die bundesweite sieben tage incidents
liegt bei 128 das rkw verweist
allerdings darauf dass wegen der
feiertage weniger getestet und gemeldet
wird
manche schülerinnen und schüler haben
wegen corona ihre schulen seit wochen
nicht von innen gesehen und wie es nach
den osterferien weitergeht ist offen
die gewerkschaft erziehung und
wissenschaft gew fordert jetzt die
abiturprüfungen in diesem jahr notfalls
ausfallen zu lassen
widerspruch kam schnell und von allen
seiten christoph distel berichtet hybrid
unterricht wechsel unterricht alleine
lärm der weg zum abi 2021 war bis
hierhin schon ein hindernislauf mit
maske und jetzt auch noch ohne
schriftliche prüfungen durchs ziel
im corona schlimmste fall jahr findet
die gew wenn die regierung anordnet voll
lockdown da müssen die schriftlichen
prüfungen ausfallen und dann muss die
leistung aus dem vorjahr an anerkennt
werden und alle bundesländer müssen die
prüfung von jedem abitur anerkennen die
abinote könnte sich also aus
mitarbeitern knoten aus den letzten zwei
schuljahren ergeben lehrerverband und
kultusminister finden das ist der
falsche vorstoß im falschen moment
ich glaube schon dass das ein etikett
wäre was den abiturientinnen
abiturienten dieses jahrgangs an haften
würde wenn sie die einzigen wären die
wegen der pandemie in anführungszeichen
keine richtige prüfung haben ablegen
können zumal dieses etikett definitiv
nicht an allen kleben würde erst
abiturprüfungen sind nämlich schon durch
in rheinland pfalz etwa ging schon im
januar los auch in schleswig-holstein
zählt schon ab übermorgen will hamburg
seine abiturienten prüfen und in den
nächsten wochen sind fast alle anderen
bundesländer dran zuletzt bayern und
thüringen die thüringerin alexandra
zählt wäre erst in sieben wochen an der
reihe
der hesse gabriel hanika in gut
zweieinhalb beide reiben sich gerade die
augen über den gew vorschlag das wäre
einfach negatives zeichen auch gegenüber
der schülerinnen und schüler die sich
jetzt vorbereiten und auch ich würde
mich dann ein bisschen wieder corona
jahrgang mit dem corona notabitur fühlen
ich wäre einfach für mich nicht
vergleichbar mit anderen
abiturjahrgängen und das wird
wahrscheinlich auch eine arbeitswelt
nicht so vergleichbar gesehen jetzt also
der zweite abiturjahrgang in corona
zeiten
das mit dem abschluss könnte noch
komplizierter werden als im letzten jahr
beim impfen ist großbritannien weiter
als wir dort haben fast 60 prozent der
einwohner die erste dosis bekommen die
instanz ist unter den wert von 50
gesunken
jetzt will die regierungen die krone
beschränkungen lockern
tomlinson kündigte vor wenigen minuten
an dass alle geschäfte friseure und
fitnessstudios in england nächste woche
wieder öffnen dürfen
ebenso wie die außengastronomie wann die
briten wieder urlaub im ausland machen
dürfen das ließ er aber offen
nach der parlamentswahl in bulgarien
zeichnet sich eine schwierige
regierungsbildung ab die konservativen
von ministerpräsident borissov sind zwar
wieder stärkste kraft allerdings ohne
die absolute mehrheit
ob borissov weiterregieren kann ist
offen wenn mehrere parteien haben
bereits im vorfeld eine koalition mit
der partei des präsidenten
ausgeschlossen
sie werfen ihm korruption vor borissov
selbst hat eine expertenregierung ins
spiel gebracht blicken wir nach florida
dort droht in der region tampa bay eine
umweltkatastrophe
ein damen mit rund zwei milliarden liter
abwasser aus einer alten
düngemittelfabrik steht offenbar kurz
davor zu brechen
eine bis zu sechs meter hohe flutwelle
wäre die folge
um den druck vom damm zu nehmen lassen
einsatzkräfte große mengen verseuchtes
wasser in die umgebung ab rund 300
häuser wurden in dem dünn besiedelten
gebiet vorsorglich evakuiert eine
umweltkatastrophe ganz anderen ausmaßes
sucht gerade die menschen indonesien
heim im osten des inselstaates in
osttimor und angrenzenden regionen haben
heftige regenfälle sturzfluten und
erdrutsche ausgelöst
mehr als 90 menschen kamen ums leben
zahlreiche häuser wurden von
schlammlawinen begraben oder fortgespült
straßen sind nicht passierbar viele
brücken eingestürzt
experten warnen vor weiteren regen und
auch auf island zeigt die natur ihre
gewalt bisher ohne
schlimme folgen für die menschen es geht
um den vulkanausbruch im westen des
inselstaats 30 kilometer vor der
hauptstadt reykjavik der fahrer das
viertel spuckte er seit fast drei wochen
feuer und lava
tausende pilgerten dorthin zu strömen
aus leuchtendem heißen gestein
unheimlich schön und ungefährlich dachte
man jetzt aber tut sich beunruhigendes
so hat cal die immer wieder brodelte es
treten giftige schwefelgase aus es ist
zwölf uhr mittags sich was tut auftut an
dem isländischen vulkan der seit wochen
glut und asche speit klaffen zwei neue
felsspalten bislang war es
naturschauspiel und nervenkitzel
seit wochen bahnt sich nun der lavastrom
seinen weg es ist wahr islams neueste
attraktion
ich finde es unglaublich ich könnte den
ganzen tag zu schauen es ist schwer zu
beschreiben diese kraft der natur und
kontrolliert 800 jahre hat der kreis
viel geschlafen vor 18 tagen ist er
erwacht ein vulkan als touristen hotspot
eine willkommene abwechslung im chor und
sofort waren die hotdogs noch nie es
gibt kleine lara stöcke man muss
aufpassen dass man sich die zähne dabei
nicht abbricht ganz ungefährlich ist das
nicht wie spätestens jetzt klar wird
behörden warnten zunächst sich dem
vulkan zu nähern erlaubten es dann heute
nun ist die sorge um besucher auf dem
feuer spuckenden berg groß wir suchen
jetzt nach wanderern sagt der örtliche
einsatzleiter und setzten hubschrauber
ein um die menschen in sicherheit zu
bringen
vulkan watching ist erst mal passé
der berg ist ab sofort für die
schaulustigen gesperrt
wieder nach deutschland da ist es bei
schnee und hagelschauern in mehreren
bundesländern zu unfällen gekommen
ein größerer ereignete sich in hessen
auf der a 3 bei idstein
dort fuhren am nachmittag mehr als 15
fahrzeuge ineinander
es gab mindestens zwei verletzte sie
wurden ins krankenhaus gebracht
mittlerweile läuft der verkehr wieder ja
wir sind beim sport und da hat borussia
dortmund morgen eine knifflige aufgabe
zu lösen haben ja das wird ein echt
harter brocken im viertelfinale der
fußball-champions-league denn manchester
city hat in vier heimspielen nur einen
treffer kassiert und die dortmunder
müssen in england auch noch auf jusuf
coco verzichten der 16 jährige fällt
verletzt bis saisonende aus ohne den
jüngsten ohne ketten santos
champions-league-reise die hummels
holland & co wollen den manchester neuen
mut sammeln für den rest der saison
der blick zurück hilft derzeit wenig am
wochenende die heimniederlage gegen
eintracht frankfurt wichtige punkte
verloren im kampf um die champions
league unruhige zeiten in dortmund das
ist die klare aufgabe sich jetzt dieser
kritik zu stellen denn diese anzunehmen
aber natürlich dann halt auch
dementsprechend eine reaktion zu zeigen
dass wir dass wir das so nicht hinnehmen
sondern dass wir dann unser unser gutes
gesicht schnellstmöglich wieder auf dem
platz bekommen auch um unzufriedenheit
im kader zu bekämpfen
in holland werden abwanderungsgedanken
nachgesagt auf reisen will der bvb
selbstvertrauen tanken und dann in der
liga die saison retten sie wollen wieder
in die champions league der weg dahin
führt das team auch über manchester
erwägt 61 kilo und hat in moskau 162 zur
hochstrecke gebracht gewichtheber
gianluca aus schwedt in der uckermark
ist deshalb neuer europameister im
stoßen
der blick verrät viel über die
kraftanstrengung von jean-luc mai in
moskau mehr als das zweieinhalbfache
seines körpergewichts liegt auf 162
kilogramm und der 22 jahre alte
sportsoldat stellt die hantel
tatsächlich hoch persönliche
bestleistung und er im gold im stoßen in
der gewichtsklasse bis 61 kg
olympia in tokio verfasst der mann vom
tsv blau-weiß spät trotzdem nach patzern
im reißen nur sechster im olympischen
zweikampf zu wenig sein europameister
titel im stoßen hat dennoch gewicht der
werde gott im zweikampf liegt übrigens
bei 333 kilogramm genau das thema
rekorde ist auch den miniatur wunderland
nicht fremd schließlich steht dort in
der hamburger speicherstadt die
weltgrößten modellbahnanlage jetzt
mitten in der pandemie ganz ohne
besucher kam der entwicklern eine
ziemlich verrückte idee ein zug der auf
mit wasser gefüllten gläsern beliebte
melodien spielt eine eigene trasse mit
extra großer lok wurde gebaut und alles
lief stabil
nun gibt es einen eintrag ins guinness
buch der rekorde zum schluss dass er
nicht wisse dass die gewitter die
winterlich wechselhaften aussichten
gleich von katja hornischer so viel von
uns an diesem feiertag schön dass sie
dabei waren
claus kleber und das heute journal um
viertel vor zehn und uns gibt's morgen
wieder 19 uhr ihn noch frohe ostern
genau meine damen und herren die
kaltfront von tief uli hat heute abend
die alpen erreicht jetzt kommen kräftige
schauer hinterher schnee regen und
graupelschauer zum teil mit blitz und
donner
sie überqueren uns morgen den ganzen tag
über schon in dieser nacht sollten sie
sich auf gefährliche straßenglätte
einstellen denn es gibt weitere schnee
regen und graupelschauer und gewitter
und die temperaturen sinken auf plus 2
grad an der nordsee und bis minus sieben
grad über schnee am alpenrand dort
steigen die werte morgen nicht über null
grad sieben grad werden es dagegen am
oberrhein und morgen gibt es immer
wieder kräftige schauer zum teil mit
blitz und donner zwischendurch zeigt
sich bei einem starken bis stürmischen
nordwest sind aber auch mal die sonne
am mittwoch gibt es weitere kräftige
schnee und schneeregen fälle bei
temperaturen von minus ein bis plus acht
grad der donnerstag wird schon ein
bisschen milder und am freitag fällt nur
noch regen aus den wolken guten abend